[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to the
GameSpot stage here at e3 2018 I'm Mike
McCarty I'll be here during the demos
all week with Lucy James hello and Ralph
Fulton hello from forts of horizon 4
which was announced earlier the week at
Microsoft yes at the expose briefing
yeah and it's going back to Lucy's turf
in the UK it's the British takeover yes
it's gonna get you out of here we're
just gonna talk about the coil for it
take it wedding the roads in England
they're a mess you'd be surprised how
many people mention that is virtually
the first thing they say when they hear
the game said retina are you modeling
the potholes so for surprising for open
world much like force were has 3 going
from the Australian outback to the UK
side so are different weather cycles or
a weather cycle at all four seasons can
you talk about the biggest changes come
to this game from the last one sure I
mean you've touched on a couple of them
there so first for me is Britain which
is our home country I feel like I've
kind of rediscovered Britain through
doing this this project working on over
the last 18 months it's so varied it's
so beautiful at such a rich sense of
history we have I'm from Scotland so we
have we've the highlands
we have Mikey now you have to say you've
Aiden bro wish for my monies there's the
most beautiful city in the UK we have
the Lake District the Yorkshire Moors
the Cotswolds all really very incredibly
beautiful and yeah like a really
seasonal country as well I did worry
about coming to LA and having to explain
what this thing seasons are I come from
we have we have incredibly distinct
seasons our country changes dramatically
from season to season and that's
something that we've wanted to
incorporate into an open-world game for
a long time and we've done it with this
game it made perfect sense with Britain
and it really changes everything in the
game yeah so during the demo the other
day on the Microsoft stage showed some
some like dialogue interaction
when the people are coming across their
friends in the game he tell me how that
will work oh so yeah so so that I think
the first thing to say is this is a
shared world games right when you play
you play with everyone else in the
community we have a phenomenal community
in horizon no they are creative they are
fun we really want to lay them to come
together bring them together to do cool
fun things in cars and this British open
world and one of the things you can do
is yeah you can interact with them when
you meet you have a really simple quick
chat system on the d-pad which allows
you to trigger some messages allows you
to interact with them and a pretty
simple but fun way and hopefully
although people to make some friends go
do fun things together that they would
have been doing on the road you can now
make your own races and share them with
your friends you totally can yeah and
that's probably one of our biggest most
fun requested feature after horizon 3
where we introduced even more sub
customization options the one thing we
didn't give our fans was this route
creator which we have no delivered
enforce our rights for so you can go
create your own point-to-point routes
you can create your own circuits and
then crucially you can share them with
your friends and with the community and
you can see other people racing on them
which i think is really cool so talk to
you a little bit briefly about the
places in England and Scotland you'll be
able to visit you mentioned the Lake
District Edinburgh are we gonna get to
go like proper are we gonna see London
like the city streets Newcastle upon
Tyne is newcastle upon tyne this is the
bit where everybody goes and do you have
my hometown my turn so so yet to your
question we always have like one city
and a horizon game because it offers
cities offer a completely different
driving experience then you know the
rural stuff the countryside and we chose
a Edinburgh for a bunch of reasons like
I said I think it's the most beautiful
city
in the UK and I'm from Glasgow so it
takes some saying that but but it really
is and that's to say we've gone for and
let you say there's Scotland there's
England there's Wales in there
there's towns there's beautiful like
really varied countryside so I think
there is real variety even before
everything starts changing completely as
the seasons roll through there's
obviously a perception like going from
Australia to relatively speaking a tiny
island like Great Britain but in terms
of like your actual map and scale how is
that how does it compare yeah I mean
I've heard that as well
I think this secret which were laying
out the bag is that we didn't build all
of Australia so actually the map and
fortune arising for is exactly the same
size the challenge for us on this game
has come from seasons so you know we're
building huge open world same sizes
personal rising threes but we're really
building at four different ways you know
because the world as you'll know it
looks completely different in autumn
from summer and from winter from autumn
you know so every season it's almost
like you've got a new world to explore
you've got new driving experiences you
get new game play crops up and
disappears with the seasons as well so
it's really worth sticking around seeing
what changes so how did the seasons
actually work like is there a set
in-game amount of time can you set them
yourself how do they work
so because it's a shared world game
everything in the game is synchronized
for all of us playing together so the
time of day we all see that the way
there it happens for everyone the season
changes for everyone as well and it's
not in-game time it's actually real
world time every real-world week the
season rolls around it progresses so you
know you're having that shared
experience you know you can watch the
Sun go down together you can count down
until the advent of winter for example
and then in a month's time you'll start
seeing that cycle again but our
commitment is to make sure that not only
are no two seasons alike and no two
winters will be alike no two Springs
will be alike as well we're gonna keep
adding to this game post launch so that
there's always new experiences new
futures new gameplay that keeps the
world evolving and alive what were some
of the things looking at Forza horizon
that you either wanted to improve upon
or like what kind of things did you
learn from that game that you carried
over to this yeah so for summarizing
three was kind of our break you know the
other games had done really well before
summarized in three really broken a
spectacular way to date we have more
than nine million players which is
phenomenal what we were able to do with
that huge number of players is observe
the way these the ways they play you
know how long they play how frequently
they play the things they do when they
when they play in the game
and a lot of what we've done in fortune
from Horizon four is really as a
response to the way we see our players
playing the way people with different
tastes approach different parts of the
game so that's been a really crucial
learning what we found and I think this
is this is probably the most important
thing is horizon isn't a binge game it's
not something that people go complete in
two weeks and then throw away it's a
game that people play really regularly
it's clearly it's it's in their recent
games lest they butch it pretty
frequently and therefore we've been able
to gear a lot of the systems a lot of
the features of the game around that
kind of behavior that kind of let play
cadence and then that kind of factors
into the weather the real-time cycle
exactly and if you think about a week
you know if you think about how many I
don't know evenings you might spend
playing a particular game and then at
the end of the week the season changes
and suddenly everything's kind of new
everything's kind of different and we've
been able to sort of structure a lot of
things for example our new Forsyth
online system you know around that sort
of frequent but not massive play
playstation and in terms of the amount
of cars you'll be able to own and you
can now property for the first time it's
that right sorry I missed that
how many cars will be able to own and
you also could not own like a diary
that's right a property that's right yes
so it's funny that I get this far into
an interview before so before we talk
about cars but I think that's probably
abut I'm guilty of it as well 450 is the
number but you know the numbers kind of
go up with every game it's like hey it's
not even more ludicrous number it's kind
of what you do in them in this game it's
really important and yet all the sort of
things that go with living the horizon
life as we call it
you can what we want you to do is feel
like you're gonna stay at Horizon
forever so you can't sleep in your car
you're gonna need a house there's a
bunch of houses you can buy all over the
country from you know quaint little
cottages right up to Edinburgh Castle
you can start a business you can get
jobs
there's a new feature called horizon
stories which follows you getting a
variety of jobs and what happens when
you do and there's also character
customization as we're on a much bigger
way than we've ever had before like
you're gonna need a change of clothes so
we've got a brilliant character
customization a system where you can
choose your every item of your outfit
your accessories your immortus as well
so it's gonna ask because obviously the
previous horizon games that they the
narrative kindness have been focused
around a music festival but in this one
it's much more kind of like real life
accepts owning four hundred and fifty
cars and multiple properties in this
economy it's not but but it's still
about the festival the festival is still
kind of like this central premise that
allows us to do all the kind of crazy
things we do in our game are with cars
the idea this time previously it's been
like good you go on a holiday it's like
a summer holiday because the game only
exists in the summer
we're notes are saying hey you're gonna
go to Horizon and live there forever
what what does that mean what are the
things you're gonna do how are you gonna
live and there's a being horizon there's
a ton of really fun things that you can
do as a result so for for me the appeal
of Forza horizon 3 which personally was
the first game in the series that I've
really got into and I still like like
you said it still sits um I recently
played it's a perfect like relaxing game
for me to play the open-world at least
but for people watching that might not
be familiar with the series could you
explain like that balance between
open-world but then also jumping right
into an activity or a new race or a new
like could you explain that structure of
course yeah and for people that aren't
familiar with the series I think the
first thing I would say is that
certainly we think about our games as
open-world games first you know and
racing games sake and that's an
important like can I have it we build a
massive open worlds and we I think with
each successive game we've got better
and filling it with cool things to do
obviously there's a ton of racing to do
but I think there's no an equal amount
of non racing stuff like
to collect stuff and we introduced co-op
in the last game and there's not a lot
of fun to be had just going exploring
with your friends in the open world and
you hit on something which I hear so
much and I think it's very integral to
the whole series it's a game that people
play to relax you know it's it's not one
of those lean end games that are really
intense and you can only play for a
short time it's very much leading back
it's about the music it's about the cars
it's about just being laid-back and
having fun in an open world yeah and I
think that's what's resonated with so
many people awesome Ralpha we are
unfortunately running out of time but
when can we expect to play Forza horizon
for we are launching on October 2nd on
Xbox one Windows 10 and we're also on
the same day and Xbox game past as well
awesome listen well we're out Fulton
thank you so much for coming on our
stage you've always appreciated and I'm
excited play Forza horizon 4 and if
you're watching from home stick around
we are about to be playing the division
2 talking about the division 2 with
Ubisoft devs we'll see you then
[Applause]